Moe moe, boo y'all!
O'Kairina, Samoa, said Ghost Jean Samoa, Jo Samoa.
And greetings and welcome to the Wild West of the Oregon
Trail.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
Woo, woo, woo.
Howdy, stranger.
Howdy, ma'am.
Right back at you.
if you're ready to get this Terry you're right right ready
in the right place I do declare I do declare you're ready to
get the the the ride of your life by what you're riding will
be a toilet seat all the way to dehydration town
Southern Oregon.
We're not in Oregon yet.
Actually, where did the Oregon Trail go to?
Wait, where did the Oregon Trail go to?
Actually.
I was like, you might be fine to see you this evening.
Hopefully none of our crew here gets that dysentery or
whatever they call it from that darn tootin' taco bell
lettuce.
Now you hear?
Wait, so it went to Oregon.
So we're not in Oregon yet, you dummy.
Are you a ghost because you died of dysentery?
That's my secret.
I'll never tell.
Yippe-kaya, me-to!
Yippe-kaya!
Oregon is the destination.
But you know what they say?
It's not about the destination.
It's about the journey.
Like an extra cute today, me-to.
I'm just a southern bale.
Oregon is the best.
Yeah?
What's so good in Oregon?
Besides their trails.
And their geese.
And their bison.
Oh, wait.
I love a good bison, though.
I do love a good bison.
The bison burger.
Gold!
You're...
There's, there do be gold in this, in this river right here.
Look at the little bun.
Oh my gosh, boy, little bun.
Here lies Minto, pepperoni and cheese.
Rice thug.
I finally caught the start of a stream, so I'm here to pay
my royalties.
Nah, you don't have to do that.
We're royalties.
Thank you for the hug, it's super.
I was watching bird videos and came across the Maribu Stork.
They remind me a lot of Ketsu Koalas.
You might get a kick out of them too, have a great streak.
I'm looking it up right now.
Maribu.
Oh, sorry the audio is a little funky.
Maribu Stork.
Oh.
That is a...
Okay, wait.
um that don't remind me no kettle koalas i remind me of my
grandpa my grandpappy oh my god what's wrong with this bird
what is wrong with this bird why does it have such a neck
and such hair it has like actually it has like a fuzzy head
disturbed I'm disturbed stop he's beautiful Wow I can't stop
looking it's like an abomination but I can't stop looking
you know my goodness show us sorry I looked up it looked it
up on my phone I looked it up on my phone
Um...
Yesterday...
Yesterday, I had a meeting.
We had Densetsu meeting, and it lasted two hours.
And all day today, I've been working on other stuff.
I'm so tired.
So today's stream might not be so long.
I apologize in advance.
Uh, I just wanted to take it easy today!
Take it easy today!
So...
Yeah, yeah.
Be nice, he's doing his best.
We plan to play the PS2 Ace Combat before 8.
Well, I played some, but I don't think we will have time to
catch up before 8.
That's okay.
We'll get there when we get there.
I haven't been, I, since I'm going on my trip next week, I
didn't want to play any, like, new long-term story games or
anything.
That's why everything week is kind of like one-off.
One-off stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
Oregon Trail 2 is my favorite game as a kid, but most people
mostly talk about the original.
I'm so stoked you're playing this.
Me too!
I love this version.
It's so funny.
Just want to say that the wiggly little ghost hanging out on
your hat's brim gives me life.
Look at him.
You usually can't see him actually jiggling on me, but he
is.
He is.
Thank you, bitch.
I will take this stream On my birthday, it's acknowledgment
of myself having done nothing wrong.
Um, happy birthday, Huey, and Merrick.
Was it productive two hours of meeting?
It was quite productive.
mush today after everything.
late meeting last night and all the work today, I'm a little
bit mush, so I'm ready to go on the trail where nothing bad
will happen.
It will be a relaxing think of it like as a cruise but on
land.
Right?
Nothing's gonna happen.
Everything's gonna be chill.
Easy vacation.
yeah just chill road trip chill chill road trip oh let's not
do that please don't spam
okay but yeah let's get into it let's do a new game the
trail journal of minto and an adventurer i'm an adventurer
Formally a...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, sorry.
Okay, kids, girl.
Formally a...
Sabrina Carpenter.
Who in...
Oh, uh, August?
Wait, where's Jack?
August 18...
No.
1844.
Set out from...
Independence to start a new life by settling in.
Oregon.
We gotta go to Oregon, though.
They didn't invent January, though.
There's the option for a Japanese princess.
How dare they not understand me?
Oregon City with carpentry skills.
$1,175 cash!
Holy cow!
And a large...
What's a con...
What's a...
Costanza?
Wow!
Worth $100.
Oh my gosh, my childhood.
Yeah, let's go!
What is that wagon?
It's the Costanza wagon.
We'll go with large.
Large and in charge.
It's worth $75.
Accompanied by five others.
Let's see.
Who wants to be on my ship?
Me?
Breasting.
Glitch face.
Oh.
I'm just picking out random guys.
Oh gosh.
Shiver.
Me, Salkin.
Pack type.
Lizard.
Yay!
We got our team.
I'm just keeping you with the ages that these currently are.
When we play again.
I will pick more names.
What a crew.
Yeah.
I wish I could have a team of a million that everybody could
join.
Good luck, Rito, to all Iboos heading on the trail.
Someone might get dysentery.
Just be...
No, nobody would.
Nobody would do that.
I transferred accounts and my subreddit.
Cody, no!
wait why would I do that that's so mean I know you've been
here I know you've been here all right let's what's the
guidebook oh practical guide to the what is this five
overland trails in the Western regions of North America
including a detailed itinerary and sound advice for the
Judas immigrant what's some advice let the world be
immigrant be aware of the fact that the overland westward
journey is not to be undertaken lightly.
Though it is not without its accompanying pleasures, it may
well be characterized by hardship and privation.
Death.
Though by no means inevitable, it is a distinct possibility.
It is, it is.
It's gonna be me.
Wait.
I'm not seeing...
Why isn't the Superchat showing up.
Wait?
Robocorps, happy birthday!
Wait, for some reason it's not showing up for me.
Did I miss it that far?
Wait, I'm checking.
My birthday was on the floor!
Glad I could hang out with my favorite ghost, though she!
Robocorps, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
And Lollipoplishers, happy birthday!
I received a Metal Gear 5 birthday from the greatest ghost
friend ever.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Let's see.
Oh, next page?
Oh wow, this is a lot of text.
I think...
We can tank it.
Right, everybody?
I think we can tank it.
Let's travel the trail.
Sprint.
Oh, my gosh.
It's been a while.
Sprint.
You're a carpenter who has come to independence in 1844 for
the purpose of setting off on a journey west to Oregon City.
You've already bought a large farm wagon, but you still need
to buy the other supplies you'll need for your journey.
As you wander the streets of Independence, you'll see
various stores that should be able to provide you with
supplies, provided you have enough cash.
You'll also, what about my credit card?
You'll also see people who may be able to give you some good
advice.
My music is so good.
Little, little, little, little, little, little, little,
little, little, little, little, little, little, little,
little, little, little, little, little, 18 months, I could
have had two kids by now.
Wow.
That's one way to think of it.
I see you're fixing to head out west too.
My husband's all raring to go, but I must say I have my
apprehensions.
Do you guys hear the popping of the sound as well?
Hmm.
I wonder if there's a way I can fix it.
Yeah.
It is kind of crunchy.
It do be popping.
Oh.
I wonder I wonder I don't know if it's the game quality or
not I can't tell if it is or not There's several places I
can play this game But
It's an old game Hopefully it's okay Hopefully it's not too
distracting What do you mean?
I hear terrible stories about vast deserts, wild animals,
disease and Indian attacks ourselves a good life here in the
east and i don't see why we have to uproot ourselves now
pardon i hear terrible stories about vast desert you like to
trade sure i've got 16 ounce bottles of ammonia she got
biscuits a hat a hatchet long pair of long underwear
have you decided the best time to leave yet the best time to
leave yet what do you think well some leave real early to
get a jump on the other wagons and to give themselves is it
a race but then there may not be much grass for the animals
and you may run into spring snows do you have any advice
it's best not to leave too late either then you may not make
it all the way before the winter snows hit I'd recommend oh
I thought she meant time of day I thought she meant like in
the morning or the evening evening of the day.
No, I'm leaving today, ma'am.
So long.
The merchants here in town offer basic packages of supplies
based on the size of one's party and estimated length of
journey.
Of course, you can shop around on your own or add to the
basic set.
So, which package would you like?
I'm not saying so far.
Oh, what advice do you have for me?
A gunsmith.
Oh, no.
Gosh, it's this guy.
Get me out of here.
We have a wagon, luckily.
What do you have, sir?
Allo, that's good for sunburns.
What's a lum?
Ammonia.
What is that for?
What are all these for?
Wait, we got furniture in here?
Oh, no.
We got some brandy.
Cinnamon, cloves, dandelion.
What about my pickles?
Uh, they don't tell you at all what they're for.
I think a hydrogen peroxide is pretty good to have.
Wait, so if I get five, how much does that cost?
That only cost me $1.40!
Okay, hydrogen peroxide is great, right?
Do you need that for...
I need eight things of garlic.
Wait, where'd it go?
Yeah, it's for...
Hydrogen peroxide's for disinfecting stuff, so I think it's
pretty good to have, no?
What's something we could get for a cold?
James fever powder.
Ah, he's a purple alcohol.
I love that stuff.
Get some grease.
I'm gonna get the fever powder.
Someone's gonna get a fever, maybe.
right i'll get three everybody can fight over it
some salt some salt wait we could get 82 pounds of salt you
guys for all this meat we're gonna be hunting wait that's so
what's a saleratus
let's get like let's get like 30 pounds wait is it 30 10
pound bags of salt okay hold on Let's get like 10.
We'll get 100 pounds of salt.
Sulfur.
Thermometer.
Sacks of tobacco.
Oh, no, no.
Not on my ship.
I am purchasing.
Hey, you looking for a wagon train to hook up with?
Our train's still in need of a few more wagons.
You want to join us?
A few more wagons.
We're planning on leaving soon.
a large group of good hard-working folks I travel alone I
wouldn't even dream of heading out on the trail alone or
even with any fewer than ten wagons really the more people
you go with the greater your chances of survival and that's
the gospel truth that's the gospel truth wait you're just
looking for more people to eat when you run out of food I
know what he's talking about um so long am I out with this
guy what we're just Wow make sure you pack the four basic
food groups beans bacon what else was the other whiskey and
lard hello friend say as your wagon train formed yet as your
way have you met to form the council that will provide
guidance and governance on your long journey I wasn't ready
for the music to be as good as it is it's so good right 22
mentioned Minutes mentioned.
The bylaws and regulations drawn up by your self-elected
council will be your only law on the trail.
You've got to keep out the bad element and make arrangements
for settling disputes.
I have here a complete and elegantly scripted constitution,
suited to all upright citizens.
Drew it up myself.
I had a year in law school, you know.
If you let me join your wagon train, I'll be glad to offer
this here constitution to you free and free.
charge so long hello hello howdy howdy hello hello hello oh
who are you heading out west so am i in fact this will be my
second trip out on the trail second this is a veteran just
from that coat i can tell this guy is an honest fellow for
real i trust everything he says tell me more travel out to
the Oregon country three years ago.
I liked it a lot, so I decided to come back east, round out
some of my relatives, and take them all back to Oregon with
me.
Wow!
He's addicted to the trail.
Find yourself a good wagon train.
That's the prime thing.
Keep moving and don't take no cutoffs.
Stick to the main trail and you'll be okay.
Thanks, sir.
The hotel.
Outfitters!
We probably need some clothes.
We need pairs of mittens!
get us four pairs of mittens we have four people right pairs
of pants no we're this is strike witches universe we don't
believe in pants raincoats socks okay like maybe like ten
pairs of socks those things are gonna go I could tell you
we're gonna get mittens pairs of long underwear Hats.
Okay, cool.
Lots of hats.
Everybody gets a hat.
Oh, hello.
Hello, friend.
Are you also preparing to set out on the trail for the new
land?
It's new land.
Yes, I am.
That's what we're doing.
My folks and me are home caught fire and burned last month.
Oh, my God.
We lost pretty near everything.
Pretty much.
Except our lives.
Praise the Lord.
So we figured we might as well.
Well, go west.
Times were so simple back then.
Man, my house burned down.
What do I do?
Guess I just leave.
I lost it all.
What are you supposed to do?
I wouldn't leave with fewer than four draft animals.
Oh, we need animals.
Six or more would be even better.
Take plenty of food and clothes.
Oh, clothes?
And maybe a few spare wagon parts.
Don't waste money or wagon space on much else.
Food, clothes.
So long.
Wait, let's go back to the clothes.
Oh, our guy had good advice, I think.
Uh, more dresses.
Uh, oh good, it shows what we already have.
Pairs of boots!
Blouses.
Mending yarn.
You know what, we'll get, this sounds good.
30 yards.
I don't know how long we'll be out on the trail, but...
Shoes?
I got boots!
Five iBOOTS plus one Minto and four sets of clothes.
Wait, am I included?
Wait, I thought it was four.
Wait.
That's the feelings of a 90s school computer lab.
Absolutely.
Wait, so we need six?
Oh.
Two more.
Oh, wait.
Pairs of pants!
six blouses six five six two two this is what everybody
wears right winter scarves we need six of them and winter
coats we need six of them wait what's cheaper the umbrellas
or the raincoat 317 six all right okay we're good we're good
the butcher the butcher never mind whatever this place is oh
no we need like oh my gosh whoa why'd the audio stop on the
bacon it's like a word oh 500 bullets yeah we get 650 pounds
of bacon do you think all of that will spoil though we'll
get a little less we'll get like 400 pounds of bacon i don't
remember how much i don't remember how and a banjo i don't
remember how much salt i bought that's a real american
actually i made bacon today because i'm gonna have breakfast
for dinner tonight.
My furthest run was 500 pounds of bacon and ammo.
Blow all your cash on banjos.
They only let me get one.
Alright, cozy up everybody.
We're getting three blankets.
Dozens candy.
Butter churn.
We're gonna get so many boxes of... Oh gosh.
Am I gonna sneeze?
The music stopped because the game had to process here.
We're gonna buy 600 pounds of bacon.
Let's get like 18 boxes.
Celery cheese.
I don't want stuff that's perishable easy though.
Cast iron stove.
That would be kind of good though.
Coffee?
Wait, why the coffee?
I don't want to get coffee pots and stuff.
We have a couple hundred pounds of candy.
Promise we'll be going to...
Welcome back to membership!
Thank you!
Oh, fishing pole.
Fishing pole.
And fishing net.
A fiddle!
Hey, they...
They blind me to
the...
Uh...
Grease.
Let's get like...
10...
We'll get 100 pounds of grease.
This is crazy.
Hunting knives.
Horses.
Do I need those or...
Wait.
I'm getting lost in the sauce a little bit.
Blasted kicks.
Thank you so much for the pie get there!
Thank you.
I'm just gonna purchase this and let's go to What's this?
Freeman returns from Second Western Journey.
Oh, hello.
Oh, pardon me.
I'm awful sorry.
I just about ran you over.
I'm kind of dumbstruck.
I ain't never seen no place like this before.
Tell me more.
Well, I'm just a farm girl and I ain't been in no big town
or city before in my life.
I don't reckon I've ever seen so many people in one place in
all my born days.
And there's so much going on.
Yeah.
With all these folks getting ready to set out on the trail?
Yeah, she probably doesn't have any advice, but...
You might want to do like most of these folks and stock up
on supplies.
I'm doing that.
If you haven't already.
And find yourself a good-sized wagon train.
That's what I've done.
Well, so long and best of luck to you.
Thank you.
Look at she does really look dumbstruck in the middle of the
street.
You're going to get run over, ma'am.
Howdy.
Oh, howdy.
Maybe I do go with that guy that says he has the, uh...
Oh!
Spare ox yolks!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh no.
I think I need tongues and axles and wheels and stuff.
Let's get like two wheels.
Two tongues.
Two axles.
Ah!
Four oxen?
Maybe?
Two wars?
Oh my gosh, they're expensive.
Six?
Six oxen?
Really?
Did you buy a gun?
Not yet.
Okay, I'll get six oxen because you guys suggested it.
All right, hold on.
Let's go get a gun.
Wait, where's that guy?
He was like... It was him.
You said, hey, I'll have this, like, pound, this, uh, this
newbie box.
I want that.
I want the newbie box.
Oh, no!
I'll get two rifles, maybe.
I got a lot of bullets, maybe.
Kegs of gunpowder.
Do I need that?
Like, 10 of them?
I think two rifles is fine.
I don't think we need the sheath.
We don't have any babies.
Okay.
This is just our first way out.
This is our first time.
We'll probably know...
Hello!
Oh!
Here, I want to go with your trip.
Hey, you looking for a wagon train to hook up with?
Our train's still in need of a few more.
We're planning on leaving soon.
We're a large group of...
I wouldn't even dream of heading out on the trail alone.
Would you like to trade?
You got...
I've got...
Um...
Spare wagon wheels.
I got that too, though.
Set of clothing.
Sets of clothing.
For an ox?
An ox?
No.
What about money?
I'm debating on if I should spend all my money or not.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Before sitting out, you need to pick a wagon train.
This is a...
This is... Train 1 is too many people.
There's so many people.
But maybe they'll feed us good, you know?
Uh...
It will be so slow.
I think so too, right?
Train 3, 25 wagons.
81 people is a lot of people.
We'll go with those 17 wagons.
Do not ford the river, end in two separate rides.
Always ford the river.
We'll go with train 2.
Alright everybody.
we're set now on the trail oh already we're at blue river
everybody we're gonna check them river conditions river
seems tranquil the depth is two and a half feet
I think we can make it.
Oh my god.
My little ox.
We're so, we're good.
What?
We've only traveled 10 miles!
We have no vegetables and no fruit.
Maybe I should go get some veggies and fruit.
We'll go into town.
Wow, so peaceful.
Sure am glad we made it here.
Oh, I went with you.
I got to find me some wood planks and maybe a carpenter so
he can help me fix my wagon.
Wait, that's me.
I'm, wait, tell me more.
Back there always, I heard a big crack while we were going
over some rough road.
Is your wagon covered?
My rear axle broke and damaged the underside of the wagon.
I was able to replace the axle.
Okay, good luck.
Good luck with that.
Wait, yeah, is our wagon covered?
I have six auctions still.
What's in here?
Oh wow, look at this guy.
Wow.
I've been told you're looking for a doctor.
Yes, we are.
We are?
I'll do the best I can.
Oh, okay.
Mind you, I don't have access to all the modern equipment
and medicines like the physicians back east.
Oh, we got a guy.
If you see any plants with reddish leaves, don't eat them or
drink the water nearby.
Those red leaves are a good sign of alkali.
Oh, if you see any plants with reddish leaves, don't eat
them or drink the water nearby.
Those leaves are a good sign, a good sign of alkali.
Even worse than fording the river is floating the wagon.
Oh my gosh, are you good?
So long.
Okay, let's, uh...
The saloon...
What's that?
Undertaker.
Signs.
What are you doing?
What are we doing wasting time here?
Let's get a move on.
What are you doing?
Get out of my face.
Blacksmith.
Whoa.
Howdy-do, neighbor.
Howdy-do.
Are you in need of my services?
You won't find a blacksmith much better than me.
Tell me more.
When I'm finished with my current batch of repairs, I'll be
pleased to help you.
I can make or repair wheel rims, shoe your animals, what
have you.
And I charge reasonable rates.
Your animals and your wagon are the only things that'll
assure your success on this journey.
Okay, thank you.
I'm looking for stuff.
Okay, let's see.
Um...
Maybe this guy's got some fruits and veggies.
We could get some celery.
We'll get... we'll get nine celery.
that up nine wait that's nine pounds oh we'll get some we'll
get five pounds of celery
and some cornmeal delicious dried veggies five five pound
five five pound okay we should be good we should be good now
we good okay we got we got fruits and veggies and what are
you say you're not from around here are you how i'm i'm
literally 10 miles away bro like you're not from around here
i'm literally your next door neighbor you could you could
walk to to my place well i bet you're with that wagon train
that's passing through you folks are more than welcome to
stock up on supplies here advice watch yourself in these
parts not everyone's as friendly as i am oh mint when
bartering we only have two rifles but we got a crap ton of
bacon and five pounds of celery celery is good celery is
delicious all right let's go continue wait suyu's around
talk to this lady maybe there's a blacksmith or carpenter
hereabouts who can help me oh no we brought her not from
around here gestures to
Pardon me, folks.
I was wondering whether you've seen this character, Nasty
Jack Finley.
Nasty Jack Finley.
He's a cattle rustler, horse thief, and all-round
troublemaker.
Oh, my God.
We're talking to the sheriff.
Tell me more about Nasty Jack Finley.
Oh, what do you do?
Nasty Jack!
Minky has a nice wagon.
Well, shucks.
Thank you, kindly.
nasty jack oh wow to get a nickname like that back in the
day tell me more he's even been robered to kill a man there
ain't no proof of it oh yet yet but he's due for a hanging
that's for sure over some horse thief devery all right let's
keep going oh wow I'm the captain!
Look at, they're all...
They're all looking at me.
Gosh!
That's a lot of...
That's a lot of, uh...
Expectation.
Oh, diary.
Today, they elected me captain.
How cool.
I will lead us to Oregon.
In a safe way.
Yeah!
Close.
How's our team?
How's our family?
Minto good.
Rest English face good.
Shiver good.
Salking good.
Pactyte good.
Horned lizard good.
I'm feeling good.
Okay, good.
We all better be good.
I don't know.
Should I accept it?
Okay.
I've had dysentery it's not fine do not recommend did
survive though good luck on your way to Oregon look at her
she's captain now oh
Lori B more emigrants there seems to be more you folks
heading west every day tell me more forgive my suspicions
but you don't have any ruffians among you a few weeks back a
party came through with several mean scoundrels in it they
tore up the local saloon and right terrorize some of the
people here.
Oh my goodness.
We do have a good store here, so you might want to visit
there before you move on.
Okay.
We'll we'll rest here.
We'll contend, or no, go into town.
There we go.
Oh, hello?
Oh, okay.
Hello!
We got a coffee saloon, we got the trail saloon, we've got
the Blacksmith...
Wait a second.
I saw you at the last house.
Say, you're not from around here, are you?
Hey!
What's this one?
Oh, this is...
Oof!
Glad to see you folks passing through.
Here for long?
No, tell me more.
Well, we can always use your business.
You know, selling supplies to wagon trains like yours is one
of the chief livelihoods here about.
I see.
This guy's going to play us a song.
Well, I just finished checking my supplies.
And I can't say we're really in need of much of anything.
Tell me more.
I think I'll mosey over to the store they got here and see
if there's anything I can use.
You might want to check your animals and be sure they're
okay.
If need be, you might be able to get a few fresh ones here
before we move on.
I see.
He's got a mosey over.
I love that word, mosey.
going we've barely made any progress you know oh now we're
now we're talking the blue mound talk to this person I think
we ought to keep going okay you know one of my brothers went
overland to Oregon last year I think we got to keep go he
wrote and said that he spent all his money in independence
he had no money left for buying supplies along the way.
That's what I almost did!
For paying ferries and tolls or for hiring Indian guides.
Oh, it's a good thing I didn't spend all my money!
Where were you from the very beginning?
I was like, oh my gosh, do I spend all my money at this
place for supplies?
I'd try to be sure always to have a little money handy.
You can get by in a tight fix with money a lot easier than
you can without it.
Oh my gosh!
Let's keep going.
Wow, we're making great progress.
There's a ferry.
The depth is three feet.
A fairly ordinary river, huh?
You think that's the banjo we bought?
I am gonna wait and rest here for a day.
Oh wait, now it's rainy.
And it's four and a half feet deep.
Oh no.
I remember playing this game decades ago.
I think my entire expedition were very happy for me,
especially when they got very sick.
Scurvy.
Hold on, we'll rest another day.
We'll rest another day.
It's just four feet now.
I don't know if we can make four feet.
Okay, rest one more day.
I didn't
even see him!
Thank you!
You just gotta believe?
Okay.
Oh!
Clean number food!
Oh, heck yeah.
Ah!
You lost the following supplies!
One five pound sack of garlic.
A pair of beans and umbrella.
Seven pounds of bacon!
And various other items.
Oh, no!
Oh, oh, man.
But we got fish.
Get advice.
What are we doing wasting time picking wild vegetables?
Who asked this guy?
Wait, five people died?
Wait, no, they didn't.
Wait.
Wait, I don't want to check.
Oh, wait, please.
Decided to board the river.
Our train lost three wagons of five people crossing the
river.
Oh my god!
Had a cat, a wagon training, train meeting to discuss our
current circumstances.
Saw eagles today near lone elm.
What majestic creatures!
Oh, I thought that...
Only I was writing in this thing.
What's so funny?
Wait.
I sure would like some fresh vegetables.
I agree.
Gather while continuing.
Yeah, we can gather.
Oh, we added two pounds.
Let's go.
This music is sending me back to my childhood.
Good luck, Indiana, Minky.
I believe you can make it to Oregon.
We are.
We're gonna make it.
Two and a half feet!
We- oh, wait.
Appears extremely treacherous.
It looks fine to me.
What do you mean?
Extremely treacherous.
Oh.
Hello.
We should wait a while before crossing.
Yeah?
Why you think that?
Hello, stranger.
I'm Martin Isaacs.
Originally from New York City.
New York City!
Wouldn't know it from looking at me now.
I guess.
Tell me more.
Man offered me a grand opportunity to see the world.
Visit some curious places.
Most items do have effects in the code, like instruments
equal morale, sewing, thread, equals clothes, lasting long,
and hammering better repairs.
I'm a city boy.
Didn't know what I was getting into.
Effet Phantom stands for Ford the River is so true.
I'm a city boy.
You have any advice?
This river looks like it could be treacherous.
The cattle don't seem any too eager to cross.
We may build a raft and try taking them across that way.
I don't think I'd try a Forden, but I'm not always the best
judge of that.
I see.
We'll wait a day.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Extremely treacherous.
But what?
Wait, it doesn't give me the option to build a raft.
What am I supposed to do?
I think we have to ford.
Oh my god.
Why would...
I was about to trust some city slicker about that river.
Ford shadowing.
what are you doing time is a wasting let's get out oh okay
let's keep going treacherous my butt oh my gosh muddy trail
everybody continue as usual continue continue we got time to
waste no fruit and it's rainy and muddy
hmm the river looks as though it may be rather difficult
three and a half three and one half feet hmm it could go
down we'll rest two days all right four guys I I think we
gotta float.
It's time to float.
Uh-oh, no, no.
Oh, we got some fish!
Whoa, what was that?
More garlic, more hat.
Oh, St. Joseph Road Junction.
St. Joe's.
Oh, do we pick?
We gotta go on the Oregon Trail!
What are you talking about?
Extreme heat!
Holy cow, it's a high of 104 degrees, you guys.
Can't we slow down?
This heat is really getting to me.
We're gonna have to stop and rest a bit.
It's hotter than a Roman candle at a 4th of July parade.
that back then?
They have, but I mean, I guess fireworks have been around
for a really long time, but that's another five dead.
No?
Played cards?
I suspect he cheats?
We're fine.
Nooned late today.
Not, what does that mean?
Come on, come on, come on.
We'll wait for the conditions to improve.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Slow down.
Slow it down, everybody.
Wait for the conditions to improve.
Okay, we're back on the trail.
August 28th.
When did we set out?
Look at all the cute little guys.
The Narrows.
I think we ought to keep going.
Oh, okay, fine.
Okay, fine.
Let's keep going.
Scurvy maxing.
No, we're gonna get some fruit, baby.
20 pounds of fresh fruit!
We're killing it, you guys.
We're gonna get there.
Oh, we're killing it and we're killing people.
No, nobody's gonna die.
Everything's fine.
We're gonna...
We're gonna slow down, but we're gonna keep going.
Oh, look at that guy!
Oh my gosh.
A lot of fruit.
There's so much fruit to pay.
But still?
Just keep going.
Stop it.
The coast of Nebraska.
Who are you?
Find scenery around these parts.
Yes, quite.
Wait, we're low on food.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Not sure if anyone in chat brought it up, but Oregon Trail
is a pioneer for roguelikes if you think about it.
Low food!
Wait, we already ate all the fruit.
Uh-oh.
Find scenery around Time is wasting Okay, okay, yeah, you're
right Continue We gotta find a We gotta find a
Just keep going Just keep going We gotta find a city We're
low on food We're low on food Uh Maybe we can find somebody
to trade With We met a man yesterday Who said he'd already
been to California Wait, no water?
His report bore a good account of the country Uh oh And the
quality of the land to be had no now we have water we're at
a river right can you hunt it doesn't let me it hasn't given
me the option right underation i've been working for other
folks all my life in the new land i'm gonna have my own land
and herd yes sir yes sir i can hear them cattle calling my
name california i hear california's the best place
california acres of wild oats
team if i for a dress haggle no haggle haggle dang it oh a
rifle haggle a dress is a deal now we have food
i think we have to keep okay okay i wish it would let me i
don't want to rest i want to keep going because we gotta get
to a town to get food right
Alright, we're making good progress.
Very nice.
Low food.
Oh.
If I rest here.
Oh no, it's just for days.
Maybe I rest for a day.
It'll let me, um.
I was gonna say maybe it'll let me hunt.
But it's not giving me the option.
Oh my gosh.
I don't see any towns, you guys.
Bad mosquitoes!
We can hardly...
sleep at night with all these mosquitoes buzzing and biting
I wouldn't advise pushing ourselves any harder I saw a
tick-tock the other day of a girl who attached a dragonfly
like a little dragonfly model to the top of her hat and it
helped keep the mosquitoes away because because they they
That's like a dragonfly is a natural predator, so they were
scared.
And apparently it works.
Holy kick of brain.
I feel like it's like an insane tech.
Because then you don't have to spray that nasty stuff on
you.
Bad mosquitoes, isn't that all of them?
Right.
I think we gotta keep going.
Just keep going.
Why wouldn't it let me hunt?
We have no food!
Morale is slipping.
Why won't it let me hunt?
I bought guns!
Two and a half feet forwarded.
We're good.
Just keep going.
Keep going.
Wait, it's 3,200 feet.
My poor oxen.
Did you buy ammo?
I did!
It said I bought ammo.
And we got...
We got gunpowder and we got ammo.
Wait, hunt!
Oh my gosh, it's right here!
Oh!
Come on.
Just a little bit more.
Alright, good, good, good.
Is there anything?
Uh...
Compass button?
Oh.
Wait, why?
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god, poor thing!
Poor thing!
No, he looked so cute!
Oh
my gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, we're so back, maybe?
Yeah, we do gotta eat.
What the?
I got that.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna, we're gonna, we're gonna eat.
We're gonna eat tonight, everybody.
The morale won't slip anymore.
I'm killing the whole bear population.
What the heck?
You gotta lead the target.
Okay, okay.
Next time there's birds, we'll get them.
We'll get them.
Wait.
Oh, oh, oh, they're so cute.
Oh, there's a whole family.
Just take them out.
It's too sad.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I was only able to carry back 100 seconds.
We have food now.
We have food.
Check the hill's conditions.
Path up that hill doesn't look very steep.
Okay, we're probably fine then.
Well, let's rest.
We'll eat, and then we'll go up the hill.
Easy!
Another hill.
The path down the hill doesn't look very steep.
I've been cogitating on this.
Cogitating?
I think we should wait for the weather and soil to improve
or attempt this hill.
What's wrong with the weather?
I need somebody else's...
I need this child's advice.
My daddy says that I should wait here until he finishes.
getting our wagon down the worst part of the hill.
Tell me more, little kid.
Danny says this is a very dangerous hill, and that I should
stay out of the way of the wagons while they're going down.
This girl sounds like she needs to blow her nose.
Maybe you should do like my daddy's done and make sure your
children aren't close to the wagons, too.
I have children?
Um, what's the condition?
Yeah, it doesn't look very steep.
Ash Hollow
This guy is always saying the same thing What do you have to
say?
Let's move on Let's move on Pass the 500 mile mark today The
mosquitoes have become quite troublesome Oh It doesn't say
that anyone's died.
So I think we're good.
Let's move.
Oh, what is this photo?
Min Morale is slipping.
I don't know what to do for them.
We're low food again.
Okay, time to hunt.
Maybe.
I won't get everything, though.
I'll get a little bit.
Fruits and veggies.
Yeah, from where?
Oh my gosh Oh my gosh There's so many of them
The lone survivor Maybe like one more thing
Oh Oh my gosh Dear Yeah Okay we're good Yay we were able to
carry it all back Yeah, yeah, baby.
Um, no fruit.
Rainy.
Let's keep going.
How many miles is it to go to?
Keep going.
We want to find some fruit or some veggies or something.
I wonder if I trade.
One.
But, like, I feel like I'm trading amongst.
Well, maybe not.
Maybe we could do this.
No, not crackers.
Dried fruit.
For two hats?
My fiddle.
I'm trying to take all my pants.
The fiddle is worth that much.
No.
Oh my gosh.
For all my meat.
Are you trying to rob me for real?
No deal.
deal.
Why do we care so much about the fruit anyway, huh?
Robidopass.
It's a fiddle made of gold.
Actually, though.
Just keep on going.
We push.
Oh, no.
Oh, we made it over that river.
But not this one.
Three feet.
Seems pretty tranquil.
We can fort it.
We got this.
Ah!
Oh man!
No!
Wait, visit the fort!
I died of Ligmo while boarding the river.
Ah!
Hey, what say you we have ourselves a wingding tonight?
A wingding?
It's been a good long time since we've had our regular
Fandango.
I agree.
Let's, everybody, we're gonna have a wingding tonight.
Tell me more.
You know what they say.
All work and no play makes Jack a dull boy.
Oh, yeah.
And we sure have been working hard out on the trail, haven't
we?
Wait, how do you...
Is that a phrase before the Shining?
A wingdang Fandango.
Wait.
That was a phrase before the Shining.
It was.
I thought it came from the Shining.
Oh.
it's old I didn't know that he saw the shining in theaters
he did we should take it easy more enjoy ourselves I'm gonna
go and see some of the others and see if and they don't feel
the same way okay but we got some stables blacksmith what is
this guy welcome folks oh please to meet you sorry we can't
boast much in the way of accommodations.
The few quarters here ain't a heap much bigger than a monk's
cell.
Let's have a wing ding and fall by a fandango.
We'll have a hoe down and a hoot nanny.
It'd be mighty appreciative of a bit of entertainment in the
evening.
Most travelers come around to share a bit of news.
And there's always somebody who can tell a good tale.
Oh, honestly, our trip has been quite eventful, huh?
You could try that bit of level ground just over yonder for
camping.
thank you supplies oh now we're talking okay let's grab some
molasses potatoes and molasses oh we got salt pork and some
tea look at 30 pounds of pork have fun at the floor as much
as you want Minto I'll be here relaxing and swimming in the
river you just crossed.
The whirlpools look pretty.
Don't go into the lie.
I'll work and no play makes Jack a dull boy's first found in
the writing in a book of Proverbs from 1659.
I had no idea.
Let's get some, let's get like some tea as well.
We're gonna splurge.
You hear that, Zach?
F.K.
in the Hootenai.
I'm all out of cornmeal.
Wait, all items.
Did I keep what I was trying to buy?
All the veggies.
There were, like, no veggies.
Oh, it did.
Okay, good, good, good.
Saddles.
Rifles.
I still have my two.
Sacks of rice.
Maybe that would be good.
Get some brandy.
Okay.
Did I lose my pan?
We'll get another one.
Or maybe an... Oh, wait.
I had, like, a cast iron.
That's what it was.
200 rifles.
Wait, maybe some hunting knives would be good.
Get, like, two of those.
Ugh.
What else?
Maybe more grease.
Yeah.
Cracker.
Maybe bread would be good to have, too.
50.
Boy, that's so expensive.
Like, 30.
They do have bullets here, but I think we're still good, to
be honest.
I'll get another couple boxes, but maybe...
We have maybe, like, 7, so we have 20.
Um...
I'm gonna purchase that for now.
Howdy, neighbor.
Howdy!
We made a mistake in calculating the flour we'd need.
Finding we were deficient, to buy a quantity of flower here
paid a dear price for it too a promoter back home said we
could reach our destination in 60 days easy so we outfitted
for that span of time but we're awful low on supplies and
we've got our ways to go yet oh my advice don't take no
advice it's advice that got us here and nobody's advice is
gonna get us out good luck with that buddy yikes Can we
sleep?
Um...
My oxen, I think, are still good.
We can get chickens!
Let's get three chickens!
Wait, that's huge!
Chickens are good!
Mm-hmm!
Yes!
Purchase my chickens.
Chickens, chickens, chickens.
I was trying to find like a thing, a cab, like a cover for
mine.
We still have our spare axles and tongues and wheels.
I think I lost two wheels though.
Maybe I'll get two more.
Maybe not.
Maybe we're fine.
We're gonna rest here for like two days.
Why is the morale?
Oh, morale is slipping now.
Okay.
I wish they had fruit and veggies though, right?
Wait, I don't think they did, right?
In the supply.
Oh, who are you?
How's doing, friends?
You must belong to that wagon train that just pulled in.
Howdy.
I'm a scout roundabout these parts.
I hire myself out to the army, wagon trains, surveyors, just
about anyone in need of my services.
Sorry I can't help you folks right now.
I got me a contract and I'm sticking to it.
Dang.
You got a banjo.
Do you have any fruit?
Five pound sack of dried fruit?
So many.
Wait, hold on.
An ox?
No deal.
All right, let's get out of here.
Purchase my chungus life.
All right, well, let's get out of here, everybody.
We're continuing on.
Register cliff.
Keep going.
Ah!
Go hunting.
Oh.
Oh, um,
one moment, please.
Okay.
Too many buffalo.
Wait, did my game save?
Rip me succumb to Stack Overflow.
I'm an adventurer.
Formerly a doctor.
And we're leaving in July.
1844.
Set out from independence.
Starting a new life.
Settling in Oregon City.
Who would like to be a part of my team?
Didn't know a sack overflow was one of the ways you could
die on this trail.
Reduced to data.
Beerlet!
Death pigeon.
Spank!
Alter!
Ain't no auto save around these parts, Moosey.
So true, so true.
Screwbert.
Alright.
Thank you, everybody.
But let me in.
I'm sorry.
There's only five.
My eyes can only see so much.
You're a doctor who came from independence.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Alright.
We were so close, you guys.
The merchants here in town offer basic packages of supplies
based on the size of one's party and estimated length of
journey.
I think I'm gonna try and get this.
Let's see.
Of course.
For six months.
So what did we get?
500 dead pounds of bacon!
We tuned in just in time!
Oh yeah!
How does it know I'm 13, though?
There can only be one chat I'm sorry, I'm sorry Please blink
less, ma'am I'm scanning Scanning everything Didn't the
other guy get screwed because he bought this pack No, no
That can't be right We still have lots of money anyway Wait
Wait Was it that?
Was that what he was saying?
No.
Wait, we got a gun, right?
Now we gotta figure out what we have.
A rifle.
Yes.
I'm gonna get another rifle, though.
One more rifle.
We only have three?
No, no, no.
We should have, like...
we should have like 15 more and we should have like five
more purchase let's get another uh wagon cover and all on
all an extra of these large farm wagon that's what we got
and we're gonna get six oxen like before purchase at least i
didn't go out to poo-poo disease.
That's so what the heck?
Game trying to stop Minto from her journey.
She will cross the trail despite it all.
She is a seasoned adventurer.
Yes!
Let's get some isopropyl alcohol.
Not isopropyl alcohol.
Hydrogen peroxide.
We get like five of them.
And whatever that fever thing was.
The fever powder.
Who knows?
It might be it might be Might be literally like chili sauce,
but we got this.
A little bit over here.
Funeral parlor?
Hi there.
What are you doing over there, huh?
Clearly haunted love.
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
What do you have?
Oh, wait.
We need clothes.
Don't we?
Wait, go back, go back.
I'm also going to get some...
some stuff for like trading like maybe wait where's where's
the clothes down here right oh my bed not that outfitters
there it is hello i need like six blouses six hats six
mittens six long undies
Six dress.
No, it's okay.
We could just work.
Three dresses.
Pairs of boots.
Six boots.
Long johns.
You'll have to rotate them.
We have 18 pairs of socks.
Six pairs of shoes.
We need six shirts.
We need six rain.
No.
No, the umbrellas were cheaper than the raincoats.
Winter clothes.
Code, six of them.
Some winter scarves, six of them.
Wait, where's my umbrella?
Maybe that was at the general score.
Hello, friend.
Get it out of my face.
The butcher.
Did you have umbrella?
What if we get some butter?
Five pounds of butter.
Oh, whoops.
It was on the third page?
Did I miss it?
This lady just wandering around in such awe.
Umbrella, umbrella.
Oh, it wouldn't let me go to this page for some reason.
Or maybe it didn't.
I just totally missed it.
Let's get five umbrellas.
Okay, I think we're ready now.
Let's go.
Too much bacon.
How much can it weigh?
I don't remember, actually.
Ain't this exciting?
all these folks but you want to train out west tell me more
how about out to the orc and find yourself goodbye goodbye
you want to trade how are you stranger oh no nobody wants to
trade with me you want to trade bought the supplies you need
oh would you like to train oh you've got dried vegetables no
tin plate why do I have six tin plates buy
more auction will that fix it like
three more
yeah baby okay um 18 wagons is 69 people nice 20 wagons 77
people 28 wagons 95 people
i'm not sure
all right let's go train one keep up all right guys oh
already oh we got this forward the river we've got this
I think we got stuck, no?
Wait, wait, wait.
We've already lost so much bacon!
Just keep going.
Just keep going, man.
Why are all the towns around here?
I know, they elected me in the middle of boarding.
What the heck?
Celebrate the fourth!
Administer peppermint!
We really need to have cholera!
Wait, I'm gonna save?
It's file name.
Me too.
Okay.
Morale's high.
We're fine.
I don't want to backseat, but can I give you a tip about
rivers in depth?
No, it's okay.
Thank you, though.
The extreme heat.
We'll slow down.
What?
Oh, search for...
Oh, sweet.
I think we ought to check it out.
Never can tell what we might find.
So true.
We should take some time to look it over.
Yeah.
Okay, search it.
Two dozen candles.
Cool.
All right.
I gotta say, if anyone's getting sick, it's someone named
Beerland.
Three and one half.
Little tricky.
I'm gonna take the ferry this time.
Oh, delay?
I reckon the only thing we can do right now is wait our turn
across.
At least we get to rest a bit.
Oh my goodness, man.
We're waiting.
Surely the ferry wouldn't tip over, right?
Nice.
Oh, I'm scared.
Two feet!
Oh, wait.
No, we forwarded this one.
It was fine before.
Yeah.
Extremely treacherous, my booty.
How's our food going?
Our pounds of bacon continue to be awesome.
That's us!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slow down.
Oh, wait.
We just had the thunderstorm.
Slow down.
Oh.
We'll rest.
We'll rest for a day.
Oh my gosh, it's super high.
Rest again.
Okay, it's a little bit better.
You might not remember, but I mentioned I'd be going to
Vexpo by myself while I managed to talk my friend into going
for the Sunday.
I don't think she's ever seen a VTuber gonna convert her.
Let's go.
I hope she has fun, Phil.
How's Virulent doing?
Oh wait, Death Pigeon is fair.
Wait, why?
Virulent's good.
Virulent's feeling good.
Yeah, drop a save.
We will, we will.
Gosh, we got so far before.
I'm so mad.
Who is it?
Listen, Terry, eh?
Don't you think it would be a good idea to stop and rest a
few few days.
Who?
Wait, who is it?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, peppermint, peppermint.
It's everybody.
It's literally everyone.
We're gonna rest for, for three days.
Morale is high, though.
The wait is only a day.
Too many people at the river.
There's too many wagons trying to cross the river right now.
We've got to wait.
Click the people button.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, whoops.
Everybody's feeling good.
I don't know who it is.
Wait.
Seems rather at five feet okay we gotta float oh my gosh I
was on the edge of my seat with that one you guys that was
too much that was too much
I'm gonna hunt a little bit oh shoot oh shoot dang it Gosh
darn it.
What?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Dang, nabbit.
Wow!
I think we're good.
Oh, yeah, okay.
A good thing we didn't keep going.
Okay, we're going on the Oregon Trail.
Oh, a stop and gather.
Stop and gather.
We need veggies, veggies, veggies, veggies.
Stop and gather, gallo.
Go as fast as possible, consume as little rations as
possible, no rest, let all the weak die.
Only one needs to make it to Oregon.
Strangers ahead.
You should keep moving, but at a distance.
They could be trouble.
Hmm.
Let's just wait here and see what they're gonna do.
Frankly, I don't like the looks of them.
I can't even, how are you supposed to know what they are?
Like what they look like, what they're doing.
You should keep moving.
I'll wait and see.
The strangers continued on their way.
What if they were like, we're the free veggies and fruit
people and we give you free veggies and fruit?
They were standing there menacingly.
Oh my gosh, look at...
Oh, slow down.
That were their cannibals.
That was literally the donner party.
That'd be crazy.
Oh, we'll slow down.
I don't want to keep waiting.
Oh.
Excuse me?
On the trail!
Whenever we noon, we have the children rest under the wagon
for a bit of shade.
Never trust the free veggie bandits.
The relentless sun draws most suddenly from our strength,
then do the walking and climbing.
Tell me more.
I'd dearly love to have a sly look in at home to see what
they're about.
I'm pleased to move on to a new life, but leaving family and
old friends is a trial.
indeed wait you left your kids there keep your faith friend
our journey then draws closer each day you left your you
left your children back at home pardon keep your faith
friend our what do you got Wow an oxen for a winter coat is
kind of crazy remember chat we only bought two rifles oh
please see you.
You folks missed a good time last night.
Another train camped close by and we had a bit of a dance.
We could have had a bit of a dance.
We could have had a hoe down, a hoot name.
Oh my gosh.
We could have had a wing ding.
All together.
That was the, that was the group.
They had, they had a literal donner party.
I declare my tired feet came to life hearing that fiddler.
I danced a plenty.
Kaiser Heron Miller was there.
neighbors and a gathering you're not old you're 30 years
young my hope will continue to see in years to come oh my
gosh GOG leave me alone update later update later shiver
thank you awesome and so wagon one with Minto resting glitch
face shiver sulk and horn lizard and pack type stopped and
founded stack overflow Oregon they lived happily ever after
answering technology questions for free on the internet
nothing bad happens smiley face good good ending good ending
let's see uh one second there we go okay wait uh so long i
will save
yes we're doing so good this time though only some people
got sick every look at that everyone's feeling good i'm
gonna have some crackers because i'm hungry slow down
thirst wait my party is suffering from thirst
next chance we get we should get ourselves some canteens or
water kegs so this won't happen again you're so right little
kid we've got to find some water and yeah i think we gotta
go faster wait there's a river right there just
altar has been bitten by a rattlesnake who the heck is altar
oh altar i'm so sorry altar you got bitten by a rattlesnake
Alter!
Alter, say something!
Where are you?
Oh, there you are!
No!
Um, use the tourniquet suction method.
Oh, oh, oh, Scrooge I do!
Um, uh, use the tourniquet suction method.
Locusts!
Do you guys know that locusts are not their own, like,
species?
So basically, when there's like, what is it?
Basically, they are just like, strange, strangely.
It's a phenomenon that happens to grasshoppers.
Yeah, like grasshoppers, yeah, they're quite literally,
yeah, super grasshoppers.
Yeah, it's basically, I believe, when there's like a drought
or something.
Yeah.
And then, yeah, they change.
It's very strange.
So they all kind of, like, it's when they get all together
due to certain environmental conditions.
And then they're all kind of, like, rubbing up against each
other and getting it and real turned on.
And then they become locusts.
Hopped up grasshoppers.
Yeah.
And then, it's kind of, that's why there's not always
locusts.
They always come in swarms.
Because it's because they're all, like, huddled.
together and they become locusts together and then they just
die isn't that so strange so then it's it's only when these
certain environmental conditions happen that you get the
locusts yeah they become a hive mind and then and then they
die and so that's why you don't see locusts like all the
time today I learned.
Yeah, you learned so much on the Mim Phantom channel.
They just eat until they die.
Yeah, exactly.
Pluribus?
I'm still watching that show.
It is a very strange phenomenon.
The wagon settlers had King Ramsey's slab.
Hence the locusts.
Returned a slab.
Um, what are they gonna do?
Their bugs just continue as usual.
Uh, everybody okay?
Oh, altar's fair.
I think the suction method worked.
We're good, we're good.
We sucked out that poison.
We chew it.
I think everything's fine.
Screwbert's okay, but he'll make it.
Let's, uh, how much...
We still got 358 pounds of bacon.
I won't hunt so much then.
We'll rest a day.
I watch Minto for the edu-ed-ed-m-ed-m-edumication.
Can he get water here?
I guess we did, because it says we have water.
We continue on.
Oh, stop and gather fruit.
Yes.
Well, last time we missed the party.
Let's just wait here and see what...
No, no.
approach them good and tug my name is ilsa viseman my
husband gustav and i are from prussia howdy gustav was a
shoemaker in berlin but times are not so good there invest
in america there is free land we here so we come here to
start a new life free land who say who's actually i own this
i need you and gustav to pay up missy imagine how awkward it
must be from a grasshopper into a your wings growing and
awkwardly dating.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, I couldn't imagine.
Do you have any advice?
We have been told always to stay on the main trail and to
check our supplies often.
That sounds like very good advice, don't you think?
Sure, wanna trade?
What you got?
Oh, a whole lot of nothing.
Oh, oh.
She looked at my, she looked at my supplies and like just
unchecked everything as I screwed.
Wait, wait, let me save the game.
That's bended!
Everybody's getting bit!
It won't let me save anymore for some reason.
Um, are you okay?
You're good.
So far, this is a foolproof method.
so stop getting bit this pigeon stop morale is so high
though everyone's feeling good okay hold on file save here
we go here we go okay nice it's already crashing a little
bit so see who's around oh hello land sakes the trail round
through here looks like it was hit by a tornado bits of
stuff scattered all about the place there's food tins and
goods of all descriptions.
Sounds like a free, um, free, free market.
I reckon lots of folks don't plan too well, and they wind up
having to lighten their loads.
When I see that abandoned flour and bacon, I can't help but
think about the hungry miles there'll be up in the
mountains.
For real!
You're right, Minto, we learned so much here, like a few
days ago, when our own mama taught us all something very
important.
I'm having a hard time remembering.
I can't quite figure out why.
Your mama.
What'd your mama teach you?
If I don't get bitten, how else can I get you to suck out
the poison?
Don't say that.
It's not me.
It's literally not me sucking it out.
Oh, my my.
Don't listen to Don't worry about what she says.
You got a lot in your load.
Spend some time thinking about the trail ahead.
You'll need food and warm clothes more than anything else.
So true.
What do you want to trade?
You got anything good?
We got flour, dried, oh, dried beans, dried fruit.
For a coffee mill, but I have only one.
I feel like everything that I buy I need.
Wait, I don't, only, okay, I'm sorry.
Sorry, but five pound sack of dried fruit for an ox is
absolute highway robbery.
Like that's insane!
One ox for apples.
Actually though!
Like how could you ask me that?
Ooh, check the river.
It's only two feet.
It's very long though.
Oh whoops.
Uh, close.
Everyone's feeling good!
We're doing crazy.
This is awesome.
Okay, save the game.
Alright, here we go.
Tanokete!
Hi!
Thanks for joining so much fun.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
We're gonna forward.
We're good.
As long as there's not a whirlpool by the end.
There's no whirlpool.
We're good.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Check the hill's conditions.
Doesn't look very steep.
and just go.
Let me trade you five nickels for your dollar.
It doesn't look very steep.
We're gonna go.
Ash Hollow.
Oh.
Hello.
Let's move on.
Fine.
My god.
Let's move on.
No please, no thank you.
Stamp the kombucha.
Let's just keep going.
Just ignore them.
Someone might get...
What's the disease you'll get?
Yellow fever.
Right?
That's for mosquitoes.
We're going to rest here a day.
I imagine we haven't slept in a bit.
Then we keep going.
Malaria.
I remember playing this game on the Apple Library.
It's fun.
Fun, this is my favorite version.
And malaria.
We've already traveled 500 miles.
Didn't that one guy get lied to and say it was 60 miles or
something?
They were trying to kill him, I think.
I think they were trying to kill him.
Let's see how much meat we got.
There's 300 pounds of bacon left.
Like we...
We have so much bacon.
bacon.
It's awesome.
I'm gonna keep going.
Oh.
Keep going?
I'm... Robo-do pass.
How is it not spoiled by now?
We got, we got bacon bait.
I mean, uh, salt baby.
Approach them.
The strangers moved away as you approach them.
They were wary of us.
We He looked like the suspicious ones!
No!
Laramie River.
Sorry, I'm gonna be saving every two seconds now.
It's just an ordinary river, three and a half feet.
I'm gonna see if we can float it, right?
Maybe they weren't human.
Creepy!
I'm gonna-
That was so scary.
Oh, this is the four!
Oh my gosh, you guys, remember before we were in such bad
condition?
Maybe spending all your money on bacon really is the strat
here.
That was so close.
Literally on the edge of my seat.
John four.
We're good on stuff, though.
Maybe they have some...
Some fruits and veggies though.
Oh, I thought that one said peanut butter.
Sack of potatoes!
We got a lot of it though.
I thought he stuck a feather in his hat.
What did I say?
Jerky!
Wait, do we hear jerky?
I don't see any jerky.
No joiky here.
He's got blankets.
We'll get some blankets.
Oh, Pemekana's jerky.
Ah, another...
Oh, I learned.
We're gonna get another, like, five...
No.
Two?
No, three.
We'll round it out to ten.
Hatchets or something?
I don't know what.
Okay.
A frying pan into a drying pan.
We'll get some grease.
Howdy.
I'm one of the regulars here at the fort.
I'm here for the adventure and the steady pay.
The conditions is tolerable, and I can send a bit of money
home to my ma.
Your mom.
I've been here since last spring.
For that, I was part of a troop down by Santa Fe.
We travel out most days, checking the area, and calling on
the immigrants.
this place to rest a while and build up your strength for
the next part of your journey.
And maybe you wouldn't mind sharing a bit of your home
cooking with the poor feller?
I have a mighty mountain for my sweet mama's fine vitals.
My sweet mama's fine vitals.
Pardon?
You might take advantage.
Sir?
I don't like the way you said that.
My mama's fine vitals.
rest here for like three days we're resting morale is high
everything's good and now we continue on our way continue
what are the vitals oh I'm gonna oh sorry I'm gonna slow
down look at the little dog death pigeon has dysentery Oh my
god, how did this happen?
How did this happen?
No!
We gotta give you the peppermint.
Slow down.
Fair.
You're feeling fair.
I'm gonna approach them again.
Why?
Why do they hate me?
$800?
Holy moly, Minto, you're absolutely filthy, stinking rich.
to that was like three years of his salary I know I can't
help it I'm just a southern bell traveling to Oregon my
daddy my daddy owned some rifles and therefore he invented
some rifle and I I just I just look pretty on the porch I
don't do nothing spiritually you do camp music I waited
You're so right!
You think they could smell the dysentery?
Probably.
Oh geez, stinking up the camp.
Death pigeon.
I wonder who's gonna be the first to die.
Nobody.
Nobody will die.
Thick dust from other wagons.
What does that mean?
Let's try to get past them other wagons.
See how they'd like to eat our dust.
Yeah.
Nothing you can do about the dust.
It was here long before we came along.
Moneybags Minky, they call her.
It'll still be here long after we're gone.
Continue as usual?
Nothing we can do, right?
Oh my gosh, it's so foggy around here.
Keep going.
A river.
Pretty tranquil.
Two and a half feet.
Oh, we got this.
Forward the river.
Easiest forwarding of my life.
oh my gosh again emigrant gap who's around here hello i
think we ought to keep going okay buddy you say that do you
have anything else to say no like you're doing a great job
is anybody dead
why are people scared of me when i approach the mass of the
ghost carrying 300 pounds of bacon i think it's probably
like 200 now at this point let's see 259 we're running out
of bacon i'm gonna i'm gonna do some hunting just a little
bit a little bit of hunting as a treat nice oh oh that was
so bad oh okay
we're good 182 all right let's keep going nice shot oh don't
Death Pigeon don't drink the water.
Why don't...
How do they get dysentery?
Why don't they boil the water they drink?
I don't understand.
All you have to do...
We have pots and pans!
Just literally boil it!
We'll slow down a little bit.
They lost a bit.
Why are we going south?
Morale is still high, though.
This is kind of crazy.
Oh my gosh, heavy fog.
Oh my gosh.
They didn't know...
Games weren't invented yet.
You're so right.
It's not like there are invisible dangers in the water.
Yeah, boiling is for the weak.
They get it on purpose to mess with you.
They're just attention seeking.
Oh no, I have dysentery.
I need help.
But we forgot to buy fire.
It boils out the next.
Chill flavor.
We're at the devil's gate.
Let's rest here for a day.
A little spooky.
Whoa!
It's getting cold.
Wow.
It's starting to get chilly.
We were struck with so much heat before an hour.
Saving the game.
Alkali water.
What does that mean?
wait see who's around i need some advice maybe we better
consult our guidebook before deciding which road to take
yeah wait we have this one itinerary oh wait where are we at
uh are we at three crossing yeah leave brief split and trail
north rugged across the sweetwater river three times south
route crosses river only once but passes through deep sand
slow going quicksand possible after it's almost my birthday
in game oh wait i missed my birthday alkaline means water
its ph is low therefore based the wagon ibu are passing
snake bites and dysentery around in a circle so me don't get
take care of them and nurse them back
made no it means high ph uh-oh uh-oh binary you need to
maybe go back to school let's see i think high risk high
reward right so let's go the north route north route the
three crossings route oh here's the first one okay first
sweet water river crossing Little tricky.
It's only two feet.
We're fording the river.
Oh, oh my gosh.
The whirlpool was walking after us.
It was coming after us.
A hundred feet, two feet.
We're fording the river.
The third crossing.
Two feet.
We're fording the river.
High risk, high reward, baby.
Ice spring slow.
Save.
Let's see, let's get some advice.
Well, have you ever seen anything like this before in your
life?
What do you mean?
Why, they said that if you dig a shallow hole round here,
you'll strike freshwater ice.
Ah.
And here it is, just like they said it'd be.
Imagine that.
Cool ice, out here in the middle of this barren wasteland.
Get a bucket and get some ice for yourself.
I can't wait to get back to my wagon, show this to the
others, and write about it in my diary.
Whoa.
Do you have a bucket?
You got...
Oh, blankets.
Not buckets.
Pounds of cheese.
I guess we'll go the South Pass.
Uh, hold on.
Looking at her, I guess...
itinerary again.
Interesting natural phenomenon where ice can be obtained
even during the summer by digging a short ways beneath the
soil.
Cool.
Wait, at this point the river is about 1-2-5 wide.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Hmm.
I guess we go to South Pass.
Let's go.
We're gonna go across the Sweetwater River once again
though.
We're in the Rocky Mountains!
This one's gonna be tough.
Fairly steep!
See who's around.
I recommend we double team the animals before trying to make
our way up this hill.
Okay.
Interesting advice.
The trail teaches you a hearty appetite.
Each day, the bacon, biscuit, and coffee tastes just as good
as any family feast we had back home.
That's not anything to do with...
Okay, let him know.
I recommend we double-team the animal.
Oh, no, no, this Freak-o is giving it his advice again.
Um...
I was either gonna say use our rope or double-team and
continue.
Let's double-team.
Oh!
Were we- Speck!
Speck!
No!
Use ropes and chains while double-teaming them!
Oh my gosh!
No!
You died of cholera!
You were fine!
Why didn't you sing?
Are you even still here?
Oh my gosh, no, he's actually dead.
No!
No, he didn't want to let you down!
You never got bit.
These are problems.
I can't believe you died.
Spank died.
Yeah, Ratu, thank you for the break.
You died as you live, double teaming the animals.
I can't see him too.
Thank you for the gift.
Oh my god.
You die in the game, you get cholera and die around.
No!
Serves a proper burial, I agree.
Oh wait, I should have gotten a rush.
Back to...
Do, do, do, do.
This is...
The switch and music is giving me deadly premonition vibes.
This is the life is beautiful soundtrack of this game.
Rest in good choice.
Thank you, Dorko.
Thank you.
Superliminal.
Thank you guys for the gifted...
Thank you.
He died IRL 2 and Sword Art Online.
No!
Don't say that!
I'm scared!
Final Sweetwater River Crossing.
Wait, it's only a foot and a half.
Forward the river.
Easiest.
Boarding of my life.
Of my afterlife.
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
We've only made it.
Or we've almost made it a thousand miles, though.
Kitty, thank you so much for that, Terran.
I was in an idle meeting.
Did anything interesting happen?
I hear...
It's like I hear his voice.
It's like...
It's...
Oh, oh, oh.
Good to do...
Wait, who's around?
How you doing?
We're in need of a rest, and this is as good a place as any.
Okay, we'll rest.
We'll rest for like two days.
It's already October.
End of October.
How's it?
How are we doing on bacon?
I'll get some more meat.
Oh, shoot.
No!
That was so bad.
Morale is still high, even though somebody literally died.
Oops.
No!
Oh, come on.
This is so bad.
I'm doing so horribly.
These things, they don't care.
Oh, even if I shoot its rump, it doesn't die.
Anybody else?
Nice.
And...
Nice!
Okay, we should be good now.
Oh, dang it.
Okay, we continue.
Pacific Springs.
Let's move on.
This guy sucks.
He sucks.
Let's move on.
Dry sandy.
Why are they calling her that?
No, everybody's still good.
It's so...
It came out of nowhere!
Oh.
Let's search the abandoned wagon.
Ah, man.
Continue as usual.
Parting of the ways.
Alright, we gotta consult our guide again.
We're at parting of the ways.
Split in the trail.
At the fork in the road, the right branch follows the sublet
cutoff, providing a shortcut to Fort Hall.
The sublet cutoff, however, is rougher and less.
drier than the main trail.
The left branch follows the main trail, which leads to Fort
Bridger.
Well, let's go to Fort Bridger, maybe.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wow, we're making crazy.
Morale is still high.
Somebody died and we just didn't care, I guess.
Don't take the shortcut.
Remember the Donner Party.
200 feet of two and a half feet.
This is a little tricky.
but I think we can ford it.
Aww!
We're too good at this.
Who are these people that are just standing around waiting
for you to give advice?
I think they're part of our party sometimes.
I say we continue on our way.
Okay.
We're going.
Nobody's tired.
Name Rock.
No, you're supposed to name it.
They were like, hey, oh, sorry.
They're like, what do you name?
It's like name, name the rock, oh we're here, we're here,
visit the fort.
Looks like as good a place as any to lay by a day and put up
some fresh supplies.
One of my oxen commenced a favor and a leg yesterday.
Commenced a favor and a leggy.
I'd like to smiddy here to take a look at the shoe.
Oh, okay.
Howdy immigrants, welcome to my fort.
Your fort.
Bridger, co-proprietor of this oasis in the wilderness.
Wow, tell me more.
Help you find everything you want here.
We've got a well-provisioned trading post, a first-rate
blacksmith, and even some fresh draft animals if you need
them.
So long.
You got any fruit?
Hey, Odie.
Supply.
Oh, wow.
You folks looking to do some trading?
Maybe.
Trading is one of the main things people do out here at
Forts.
Why, it's pertinent to your former energy.
for some souls.
It's one of the things that may, one of the main things
people do here out here.
F-forts.
It's one of the main things people do out here.
Keep a sharp eye out.
Did you like the train?
Oh, you got some butter churn.
Dried vegetables.
For a pair of boots.
Well, I have five pairs.
That's all I need.
I don't need him!
My god!
No, I'm good.
Let's see what he's good.
We are running out of bacon.
We can get another, like, 55 pounds.
Look how much money I have.
We are so good.
is it
cheese let's get some cheese let's get 10 pounds of cheese
let's go
sacks of oats oh yeah baby i love oats brother may i have
some oats or trade spanks boots lightly
Man, how am I running out of pans?
I guess they're getting used up and breaking and stuff.
They don't make them like they used to, huh?
Okay, we'll take a rest here for like two days.
It's already, it's starting to get cold though.
Uh, guide?
Where are we going?
Gravespring?
Wait, where do we head up at?
Look how much we still have to go, guys.
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
We're at Bridger.
Did I pass it?
Here we go.
Here we are.
Grave spring.
Spring to the left of the trail, rough trail follows.
I don't know.
Salt Lake alternate route?
No!
Abandon night?
No, I will not.
We will rest here a while.
We'll rest here for a week if I have to.
My animal will be fine.
I will not abandon my ox.
Thirst?
Uh-oh.
Um.
We are getting right desperate.
We won't last much longer without water.
We'll go faster.
We're almost to the river.
Look at that goat.
We're inside of thirst!
Wait.
Oh god.
They're very...
Scrooge critical, alter bad, spank is dead, death pigeon is
critical, virulent is dead.
Me?
I'm feeling good.
Oh, oh.
If we've been a little more cautious, maybe this wouldn't
have happened.
Shut your freaking mouth.
Someone was getting double rations because somebody said
that they needed more water.
Go on without me.
I hate to mention such a gruesome thing, but we have to make
sure the grave is deep and covered with stones, or well
hidden.
Otherwise, the wolves or coyotes might dig it up.
Guys, next time you rest up, maybe be close to a river.
Oh, no.
Don't pick me for the next one.
Let's try to find some kind of marker.
a stone, or at least a piece of wood to inscribe their name
and leave it on the grave.
Okay, thanks, kid.
Whistle!
Remember me!
I'll tear in your hole that I have!
If you would just wait and watch!
We were soaked!
It's rain!
but I have plenty of water.
I think you forgot to get the bottled water.
Oh my god.
Thank goodness the ox is okay.
We were so close.
The needles.
Wow.
We have no water still.
Uh-oh.
I told you only one needs to make it.
Wait, we were just out.
a river why do we have no water rough trail hello hello
hello let's keep going okay oh we're gonna we're gonna rest
we're gonna rest for two days we're gonna get some water
from resting okay we're now.
Hello!
Alter is okay!
Less heads to feed now.
I'm so sad right now.
Let us all say one good thing about virulent, death pigeon,
spank, and screwbert.
Virulent virulent Barely got bitten by snakes.
And only had cholera.
And Death Pigeon had it coming because of your name.
And Spank went out doing what he loves.
Spank.
Alter is fun.
And Scooper is scrubbing up in heaven right now.
Dying of thirst.
I prioritized my ox over you.
I didn't know there was no water nearby.
I only thought of...
Oh, I...
What have I done?
I can trade all these blankets now.
Okay, let's go.
Wait, all these boots...
Everything.
Okay, we're fine.
Extreme cold!
Wait, no water again?
What are you talking about?
We'll continue as usual.
If you go fast to heat up, you know.
Fallen rocks!
Uh, there's no wait for the- If we all pitch in, we can
clear our path through these rocks in just a few hours.
So true.
Let's get our tools.
Try to clear the path you were unable to clear the path find
another path you were unable to find another path there must
be another path we can take I I literally died Janice you
made the right choice at this rate nobody will be out to
blame you
holy moly looks like there was an avalanche I don't see how
we can clear that up let's find another way What is waiting
for the conditions do?
It doesn't even do anything, right?
We gotta continue over the obstruction.
Wait.
Oh, the conditions have not improved.
We waited like a week.
No, no, no, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
No, 1,092 miles traveled.
This can't be another group of emigrants.
Elter has a broken wrist.
Set the bone.
Exercise the broken bone.
What does that mean?
We're going to apply the splint.
Go faster.
You're almost there.
Oh, it's snowing and the morale is slipping.
Oh my god.
fallen rocks oh my god oh my god the fallen rocks took like
a week we suffered a terrible loss virulent has died of
thirst we plan to provide a prayer proper burial a very sad
day death pigeon has died of thirst we will provide a proper
burial we suffered a terrible loss scruper does die of
thirst we plan to provide Everybody remember November 13th,
1844.
Oh, no!
We'll rest here for a day.
The river appears to be frozen.
I think we can make it.
That's a scary sound.
November 13th, 1844, Pratt's Pass Canyon.
It's icy and fairly steep.
What are you doing?
Why are you posed like that?
My dead burned wagon wheel broke away his back and took me
from here all day to find someone willing to trade me for a
new one.
A heap of trouble this.
I don't know.
Who?
I need to know.
No.
look for someone else good day to you folks my name is
philip maddox i'm an artist with this surveying expedition
howdy the u.s government has commissioned us to map the land
and to bring back some illustrations of the indians as well
as the plant and animal life hereabouts you have any advice
your supplies often can't stress too much the importance of
that and don't waste a whole lot of time at least if it
isn't an emergency you won't get You'll delay your progress
and you risk antagonizing the local Indians.
Oh, if I hunt too much.
Oh, okay, okay.
I have six winter goats.
I only...
Let's see, hold on.
What else you got, man?
Wait, actually, hold on.
I'm gonna save my game.
It's been a minute.
Yeah.
Um, well...
None of my team is given...
Is it because everybody is dead?
Nobody is giving me advice?
Alter is bad!
Wait, I'm feeling fair.
Oh, no.
Okay, we're gonna
use...
If there are any injuries, we have to make sure the wounds
are treated properly.
We don't want them to get infected.
Why are we asking this kid for advice?
Ropes and chains.
Okay, we're...
Extreme cold.
Low morale.
Oh, my gosh.
Continue as usual.
it from supplies we got that easy easy hogsback summit our
tongue broke that's okay they're the only survivor yeah the
bobcat was so cute slow-going howdy names Jubilation
Higginbottom Jubilation Higbottom you can call me Julie
Julie I don't want to hear any smart cracks about that
neither tell me more I'm a prospector, but I'm just coming
to the realization that there ain't too much around here
worth prospecting.
So I think I'll move on.
Do you have any advice?
Sorry, but I gave up giving advice years ago.
Nearly got myself shot back in 32 by a fella who blamed me
for his misfortune.
All because I gave him some advice.
Dang.
Will you scatter their ashes to the Heartless Sea?
I'll never scatter your ashes to the Heartless Sea.
You're all diamonds.
Dixie Hollow.
I see him fairly steep.
Okay, we're gonna...
Who are you?
Good to see you, friend.
You know, I spent some time out west, and now I'm traveling
back east to fetch my family.
Oh, tell me more.
Hope you're prepared.
You'll be seeing quite a bit of the elephant further on.
Elephants?
Since your animals is already mighty worn, it's gonna be
rough.
Feet ain't always plentiful, and water sometimes rats
scanty.
Uh-oh.
So long.
We got this, we got this.
Um...
Ropes and chains.
Ropes and chains?
Okay, we got it.
We're gonna rest here for a day.
More house slipping!
Alter is bad!
I'm feeling okay.
I'm fine.
We're fine.
No, we- oh, now I was gonna say- I was literally about to
say no, we have water.
Now we have- Little Dutch Hollow.
Back home, I used to enjoy nothing more than going hunting.
Now I can't hardly abide.
Why are you dogs?
I'm all wore out from the traveling to take no pleasure at
the table.
No, a jubilation!
Oh, oh, oh.
Fairly steep.
We can double team.
Yes, yes, yes.
We're like that goat right there.
Such a text-heavy game.
It's amazing to think about how the people who actually did
this trail would not be able to play this game because it
would not be released until 1996.
And they're long dead.
Not everybody, maybe.
Oh, wait.
It's 18.
Never mind.
Everybody's dead.
Just like my team.
Alter's bad.
I'm good.
Feeling great.
I think it's time we be moving on now.
Okay, kid.
Sure.
Another thing?
Oh, my gosh.
Fairly steep.
Oh, we're on the descent.
We're on the descent.
Marty, you know, I've been trapping and trading in these
Yarr Mountains for near 20 years.
Dang.
Tell me more.
Last year, a young grizzly invited itself to breakfast.
In the tassel, it bit me right on the shoulder.
I reckon I'm not going to take that from man or beast.
So I bit it right back.
That thar bar ain't bothered us all since.
I have nine ox.
gosh here we'll do two no hackle hatchet sure oh we can only
trade one thing okay continue down the hill okay we're good
thirst go faster death
is part of life we must shore ourselves up and keep moving
on
We ought to hold a funeral service of some kind.
What a shame it is to bury our loved ones out in the
wilderness, but it has to be.
Everybody's given up.
We'll rest here for a day.
Oh, it's still snowing.
Oh, dear.
I have cracked chapped.
No!
No, I have cracked, chapped lips, whatever, whatever should
I do.
We're so close.
Oh, we're at steep hill.
I wonder if it's steep.
Very steep.
There are more ox than people now.
Oh, we made it.
Are your expedition team members doing great?
I withdraw my application for the next run You already put
it in We Yeah, I need to get some lip balm for me Day 657 My
party is dead and my lips are chaffed It's over I think we
do not be poor No!
How am I supposed to get water?
I'm Mr. Wasting Let's get out Okay.
Extreme cold.
Continue as usual.
Whoa, we're traveling.
We're traveling a long way.
We have water, though.
Slow down.
Check the river conditions.
It's frozen.
Yeah, go, go, go.
Cross.
Everyone's dead and Minto's are like, not chapped lips.
I know.
My gosh.
My problems are so tough.
I mean, can I apply for the death cult?
I mean, next run.
I have low morale.
I don't even...
If I can't get there with you guys, what's the point?
I'm so sad.
Are we almost there?
Surely.
Oregon Trail more like all-gone trail.
Should be frozen, yeah.
Scary sounds, scary sounds.
I have to make it to Oregon for you guys.
Malad, Malad River.
It should be frozen, yeah.
Malad River.
Happy New Year!
Yeah!
Akemashte omedito kuzaiimasu.
Animals are exhausted.
No meat!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh, my bad.
Stop and rest for a while.
We'll rest for two days.
And then I'm gonna hunt.
There's gotta be something here.
Not everything can be hibernating, right?
Go bunny.
Oops.
Oops, that might have been my only food.
Yeah.
We got one.
I'm tired, boss.
Come on.
Oh, little bun.
Nice.
Anybody else?
Come on.
Oh.
A hidden creature.
Oh, a whole family of them.
Nice.
Take them out one by one.
Okay.
We got 12 pounds.
That's it.
Slow down.
Oh my gosh, it's negative 7.
Rattlesnake pass.
That reminds me of everybody who got bitten by the
rattlesnake.
Neo-gapenism.
Welcome to Bumpusha, thank you.
Caffeine.
Please know I'm baking bread.
I don't want to go on that death wagon.
Five dead.
Another five lost to the void.
The wagon is cursed.
How?
Yeah, we would have loved it.
You guys, look, you guys would have loved it here.
I'm feeling good.
Low morale.
Who?
I got a...
I got my favorite.
We just rested.
We don't need to rest again.
Are we almost there?
Surely.
Surely we're almost there.
Oh my gosh.
Much more.
Pequod Mountains.
Do I still have chap lips?
Oh.
No, I know.
I'm feeling good.
Search it.
Wow!
Three pairs of long underwear!
Nice!
I'm still in Utah.
So...
No, no, we can replace it for my supplies.
I got supplies.
I have no meat!
I need to hunt again.
Very important.
I'm hunting rabbits.
No, come on!
Nice.
What is that?
Something.
Whatever it is, I took it out.
Little piggy.
There's still two to three states away.
Oh, that was terrible.
My bad.
Yeah.
Any meat, any meat.
Food is food.
We just took used underwear from an abandoned...
How do we know it's a...
used.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, one shot, one kill.
Oh.
The hunter.
We might be good now.
Oh.
We were only.
We were only able to carry 94 pounds.
Oh.
We shot so much though.
I thought that because I thought it was based off of the
Stop them rest a while I thought it was based off of the
weight of our wagon Maybe it's based off of how many people
That we have, I can only carry Uh oh All of our stuff is
really running ragged you guys It's just me left It's just
me Nobody will help me
It's all me.
I do have less mouths to feed, that's true.
We're at Salt Lake Cut-Off Junction.
Uh...
Oh, here.
The California Trail continues to the southwest.
We don't want to go south, no?
The road to the Great Salt Lake Valley comes in from the
southeast.
Let's go to the Fort Hall.
City of Rocks, are you rocking just for me?
Well, hello.
Find scenery around these parts.
Sure.
City of Rocks.
Everyone's dead and it's all there for me to see.
I have scurvy!
I look like a poor Victorian child in my blanket.
You were unable to find any edible...
Oh gosh!
Uh-oh.
Wait, I think I might die.
Irritability?
Stiff sore joints, swollen bleeding guns!
It might be, it might be...
Slow down!
My joints hurt!
How do you have the best kvadic time?
Just go!
Let me die!
Am I gonna die?
No, I'm still... Everybody else is...
I'm gonna... I'll join you all soon!
Oregon Trail!
Just go.
We can make it.
Oh my gosh, just go.
Just go.
Just keep going.
A turn for the worst.
Binto has taken a turn for the worst.
You were unable to find any edible plants.
the music is so sad oh the wagon train morale is low what do
you want me to do I'm sick of having scurvy let's rest a
while let's rest two days surely I won't die
ah And don't call me Shirley.
And don't call me Shirley.
Ah,
suddenly I'm craving some orange juice.
Oh, this, I died because they yelled at me.
You guys need to be nice to me or else I'll die of...
Still die of cringe.
Read me.
No.
My diary.
No, nobody can write my entry.
Morale is very low.
We are going to continue.
Minto died.
It's a mighty cold today.
We're going to continue as usual.
I was your captain.
Do you have...
You have no souls!
I hope you all don or party yourselves!
I started showing symptoms of scurvy.
We're going...
We're trying our best to go look for edible plants.
That's it.
Well, guys, not even a proper burial.
That was our Oregon Trail.
I would like to try this again sometimes, and sometime when
we...
I know we can make it with a full team.
Maybe losing one person.
Not even a terrible day for you.
It's because I'm already dead.
It's nothing new.
new.
Kieran lies, Minto.
They didn't call her Shirley.
They called her captain and they called her boss and they
also called her dead.
VLON!
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Once a month's tradition?
That would be fine.
I hope you guys enjoyed this.
I've learned my lesson to not not take a whole week to let
my oxen rest.
They only too and everybody needs water.
Ghostaku!
Welcome back, thank you!
Boss, I'm thinking maybe Oregon stinks, so Akiba?
Akiba Trail, yeah.
I enjoyed it even though I died.
Thank you for joining my trip.
So funny.
Nice try, nice try.
That was so funny.
I got got I didn't even get got by the chap lips.
I got got by scurvy.
What am I a pirate?
Thanks for taking taking me on the trip remember to drink
your water so you don't end up like drink water drink orange
juice suck out the poison it works every time
but that was so fun I'm gonna go eat dinner now and drink
orange juice not get scurvy
at least.
Yeah, what a sad way to go.
I didn't die as pathetically as needing a drop of water.
No.
I just needed a little juice.
Thanks for the darn tune adventure.
Enjoy all your actual baking cat and maybe lots and lots of
water and orange juice.
Aside from the ox and don't wait for the landslide to wander
off.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you, Dargo.
Thank you.
Make me Thank you!
I'm gonna go have dinner for breakfast, guys.
I hope you enjoyed this.
It was a lot of fun for me, too.
This is the Oregon Trail I always want to play, so...
I hope you guys have a good...
Day, have a good night, have a good time zone!
Wait, breakfast for dinner.
Yes.
Breakfast for dinner.
That's what I've been.
Eat-a-dashai!
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.